conditions appear to be improving in the
two hardest-hit European countries
Italy's daily death toll has declined
over the past two weeks and Spain
reported fewer deaths on each of the
last four days Britain's Prime Minister
Boris Johnson is in a hospital for tests
this morning because he's had persistent
coronavirus symptoms for more than a
week as Charlie d'Agata reports
officials say Johnson is still in charge
the Prime Minister last appeared in
public when he popped out of Downing
Street on Thursday night to clap in
support of British health care workers
the next morning looking visibly rundown
on Twitter although I'm feeling better
and I've done my my seven days of
isolation alas I still have one of the
symptoms and widest symptom of I have a
temperature that persistent temperature
ten days after testing positive for
kovat 19 prompted doctors to send the 55
year old to the hospital for what a
spokesperson described as a
precautionary step and routine tests
he's faced harsh criticism for acting
too slowly against the virus just one
month ago unconcerned of close contact
with coronavirus patients I shook hands
with everybody you'll be pleased to know
that I continued to shake hands now the
wrath of the virus has taken hold in
Britain which has seen its three
deadliest days yet and the news of
Johnson's hospitalization broke just an
hour after Queen Elizabeth delivered a
rare televised speech evoking Britain's
wartime spirit we should take comfort
that while we may have more still to
endure better days will return we will
be with our friends again we will be
with our families again we will meet
again
with Boris Johnson now here at the
hospital the foreign minister will now
chair the daily crisis briefings but
Downing Street says the Prime Minister
remains in control of the government
Tony Charlie d'Agata for us in London
Charlie thank you very much